- He is the clever and
very funny political junkie
you can catch every weeknight
on "Late Night with Seth Meyers,"
one of my favorite shows
on TV, not just NBC.
He is, you guessed it, my friend as well.
Seth Myers, are you there?
- Yes!
And we're matching
denim shirts, I love it.
- We called each other, I was
like, you wear your denim.
- Yeah, it's Jay Leno Day.
- I literally, I know right.
Actually, this does look
like I'm working on a car,
it's a whole onesie, but anyway.
- [Seth] Oh wow.
- I know, and I only have,
four things I keep switching through
because I'm here in
Montana, I have no clothes,
and I just keep switching
to just different shirts, it's fine.
- Yeah, I need to start keeping a list,
because I'm definitely, I'm
just trying to go two weeks
before I reuse a shirt on
television, but I'm not sure.
- Oh.
- But I think I've had some holes, yeah.
- I have definitely not accomplished that,
people are seeing the same
black top over and over again,
but, I'm in Montana,
I don't have anything but
warm clothes here, whatever.
But, so have you had a conversation
in the past two months
that didn't start with,
"How's quarantine going?"
- No, I really haven't.
(both laughing)
- I know, I mean it's fascinating,
there's never been anything
that everybody's been
experience at once like this.
You know, you had friends
who cared about some things,
and friends who cared about other things,
but it really is, it would be crazy
to start a conversation without asking.
- Well, you feel rude, yeah.
- Yeah.
And you never know what
the answer is going to be,
unfortunately, 'cause I
have friends and family
who have been affected by COVID,
so even on my most
depressing days, I'm like,
"Okay, I'm healthy, I'm
healthy," just keep saying that.
- I feel the same way,
I feel the same way.
- Yeah, well, we may
be in a different time,
but I wanted to keep our
day-drinking tradition alive,
so I brought a beverage.
Do you have one?
- I had some grain
alcohol and I finished it.
- (laughs) Well, that's okay,
- Oh, there's no lid
I can toast it, I'm
toasting you, here we go.
- Cheers. (laughs)
- I'm not gonna lie, this was
left over from Tuesday night,
the lives in the "The
Voice," it's a little weird.
But let's, I wanted to mention something,
because I used a GIF of
you, because I love you,
and it's funny, so I was
having the worst day,
my dryer broke, my clothes ended up,
we have no clothesline,
so I just had to hang them
on the back porch kind of
area, and they flew off,
into the forest and I had
to go find all of them.
And anyway, it was a really rough day,
and then I got back in
and I had all these texts
and they were like, "Man, so
now there's murder hornets."
And I was like, "Wait, what?"
And I started looking up what
the hell a murder hornet was.
And then I used your
GIF that was like, sure,
of course this is happening, why not?
Have you heard of murder hornets?
- No, I mean I had on, this weekend
reading a newspaper article
about it, and again,
it was just one of those things.
We did a thing on our show
called "Murder Hornets,"
which is, we don't have
the bandwidth to be worried
about you at this moment.
If you looking to make a
splash, murder hornets,
you picked the wrong time,
I think you need to do it
before or after a pandemic,
not in the middle of it.
I think there are people
who are, at this point,
would be terrified about
murder hornets any other time,
that are now like, "Great,
whatever, bring it on,
"let's just have it all at once."
- I'm honestly, this happened
to me the other day too,
there was an earthquake
here, and I didn't know
earthquakes happened in
Montana, and I was just like,
"When are the locusts coming?"
Everything is going to crap,
I don't know what's happening.
But it's not, that was a bad day.
But anyway, I just thought it was funny,
because they're called
murder hornets apparently,
because they decapitate honeybees.
They're just taking their
head off, which I was like,
"of course we would have something
called a murder hornet right now."
How is it, doing your show from an attic?
Why did you choose your
attic, I'm curious?
- We moved around to a
lot of different rooms.
we were in a neighbor's garage,
and that was a little cold and echoey.
And then I tried a hallway, and that was,
I looked a little bit like a ghost.
And then ultimately, this
was both quiet, and also
the kids couldn't get up here, and then
just as it started, the
older one got tall enough
to lift the latch, and so
now every now and then,
the stairs are sort of right
there, every now and then
I'll see his little towhead
pop up, and just one of these.
And it's really, the most
embarrassing thing about this,
is that my kids know that I do a show,
that's Daddy's job, is he does a show.
And now I'm worried that
they think all the times
I've left our apartment in
New York to go to 30 Rock
they think I'm also just going
into a weird little attic.
I wanna be like, no there's
a big, Daddy's a big deal.
- Yeah, I'm a big deal, yeah.
- There's a big, there's lights.
- I know, but it's weird, your kids
are going to start doing
this because River and Remy,
the younger ones of our
four, they start to think
that everyone's Mom and Dad
do the same kind of thing.
So they don't understand it quite yet,
they are four and five, so
they kind of think like,
"Well everybody has a
studio in their house
"and everyone has a mom who
sits in front of a camera
"and talks to a bunch of people."
It's such a funny thing to watch kids,
kind of get it.
- The funny thing, though
is when it's over and then they say,
"Why are you going to
work, you did it at home.
"I just think you want to leave us
"for eight hours"
- Think you want to leave us.
- I'll have to have to
sit them down and say,
"that is why, I want to be away,
in order to love you as much we need to,
"we have to be away from you."
- You do need alone time,
I am with you on that.
All jokes aside, do you
like working at home?
Or has it been, its
been exhausting for me.
- It's exhausting, I mean,
I miss the camaraderie.
I've always valued how
luck I am to have a job
where you are surrounded by people.
Creative people, people
who make you laugh.
So I miss that a lot, I
also feel lucky enough
that there is a way to do
it, that we figured out
a way to do it from home.
But that part of it is the hardest part,
not being around people.
- [Kelly] I agree.
But watching your show, I've
noticed the stack of books
next to you, so is that your reading list,
or are you just trying to look impressive?
- I'm just trying to look impressive.
I highly recommend "The Thorn
Birds," that's a good book.
- I've actually read that, and I actually,
they made a series on it, I've seen it
- Miniseries, yeah, 1983.
This is a very little red
"Thorn Birds 2, More Thorns"
- (laughs) I love...
- And an almost never read,
"Thorn Birds 3, Things
be Getting Thornier."
That was a very--
- I actually did (noise
drowns out voice) read it.
That's so funny.
- Very badly reviewed book.
- I love you for it.
- I basically think that,
people have pointed out,
we're basically seeing
everybody's bookshelf,
and that's just way too much,
I don't want to reveal
that much about myself.
So it's mostly every
book I put up has been
either books I love or a joke.
Like, I put up "Common
Sense Pest Control,"
I thought that was...
(both chattering)
- I'm gonna start doing
it, and I'm going to put
my favorite childhood ones,
my world doll collection or something.
- I think, and again, I don't know,
I don't want to judge too hard because
I've never written a book,
and if I wrote a book
I might very well put it behind me.
But I think it's funny
the amount of people,
their book is behind them.
- Their own thing, isn't
that the worst though?
When you're, I'm so
bad at that in general,
in this industry, even for now 20 years.
I'm so bad at promoting myself, I hate it.
I feel like such a tool,
even if it's my song,
I'm like, "Yeah, either
listen to it or don't,
"or read my children's book or don't."
I'm the worst salesmen ever, but I do,
I laugh at that too, or when
you go to someone's house,
and there's a wall of all their accolades,
right when you walk in, and
there's nothing wrong with it,
but I'm like, "Mine's
in my attic." (laughs)
- I think, right, I think
there's a happy medium
between foyer and attic, and you know,
I encourage you to bring
it a little farther down.
You know, for me, I like
to, and by the way I think
I have fewer accolades, but
you know, put it somewhere
little Easter egg for people.
- Yeah, no, it's just funny,
right when you walk in
I'm like, "Well, you're proud, it's cool."
- So, are your kids,
are your boys enjoying
that you are home everyday, do you get to,
because I get to do a lot more things
than I normally would with them.
- Yeah, it's been great, it's
genuinely has been great.
And out of necessity, we
have to upload the show
a lot earlier than we would
have to in the studio,
so I have way more time with them.
And the whole first month,
I just kept thinking,
I'm so glad I get to put
my kids to bed at night,
and now, ideally, I'll never do it again.
- I feel like I knocked it out.
Also, my son, the four-year-old,
does an hour of Zoom a day for school,
because he's just four.
- No my kid does the same thing, yeah.
- Today he yelled because
he pressed something,
he was Zooming on an
iPad, and he screamed that
he had turned it off, and
then I went down to fix it,
and he was just sitting,
he had his pants off,
and I was like, "Did
you take your pants off
after you turned it off?"
And he goes, "yeah."
And I was like, 'Thank
god, because you might
be on a watch list, so
let's get your pants back on
and turn--
- That's the most amazing thing
you'll see from reporters,
from their home.
The one guy was in his shorts
and he had no idea the screen
was that wide, that's amazing.